[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
problèmes de recharge parce que je sais
pas si c'est votre cas
mais moi j'ai souvent fait valoir des
problèmes de recharge sur mon smartphone
et tous mes objets connectés et à force
ça devient hyper relou donc j'ai décidé
de vous parler de recharge tous les
problèmes de recharge de batterie sur ce
comme ça de batterie externe
c'est d'avoir une solution qui vous
permet lors de vos déplacements d'avoir
un truc qui est vraiment top
et là on a un truc qui est pas mal c'est
la société omar ce qui m'a contacté et
qui m'a dit on aimerait bien vous pas
une autre produit parce que franchement
peut être pas mal et notamment lorsque
vous voyagez alors j'ai regardé à
regarder j'ai regardé réfléchi est ce
que ce produit a un intérêt et au final
je trouve que se produit un intérêt
parce que vous avez une batterie de 20
mille cent millions terreur qui vous
permet de faire vachement de recharge
c'est une espèce de grosse base de
recharge qui vous permet de recharger
tous vos produits va milieu de terrain
pourrait franchement m
vous pouvez câble est ce que vous les
tablettes ordinateurs smartphones seront
totalement à tous ceux qui n'ont pas
forcément de prises électriques avec eux
ça peut être super cool mais juste avant
mars une autre truc
[Musique]
yes de go la haye est ce ça c'est cool
vous allez voir on va où les
autocollants c'est génial ça vous allez
voir en vrai dans quelques jours c'est
des lunettes de soleil avec en fait là
c'est un espèce de haut parleurs qui
vient ce paquet contre vos et vous avez
de la musique en fête dans votre tête
alors dans votre tête par résonance ça a
l'air d'être super cool on va le tester
et à mon avis là dessus il ya de quoi se
marrer next
yes acer swift 7 tu faisais pareil a pas
très longtemps la serre si vous en
souvenez quand on était à berlin
halifa a regardé toutes les nouveautés
un petit peu de sr et là c'est une
nouvelle bécane c'est le swift e set je
suis hyper content parce que comme je
vous l'aï dit on parle beaucoup de
smartphones parce que c'est l'objet de
techno que tout le monde a mais j'ai
aussi envie de parler d'autre chose j'ai
envie de vous parler de montres
connectés ça tombe bien parce que dans
deux trois trucs on à la tique watch pro
qu'on va regarder on à la galaxie watch
l'ami bob trois des plus petits pour les
sportifs
c'est pas mal de choc dont va continuer
à parler de smartphones et rassurez vous
j'ai lu à 6 plus j'ai pas mal de trucs
donc tout ça je vous invite à faire une
chose pour qu'on entre très bientôt
c'est à vous abonner et à rester
connectés
mais pour aujourd'hui pour aujourd'hui
on a parlé du novo novo novu novu
nouveau qui en fait une batterie
portative de vingt mille cent millions
terreur 60 watts et je pense que ça
pourra sauver la vie à plus d'une
personne si ça vous intéresse je vous
aime bien lien en bas d'un rescrit psion
s'écoutent un peu moins 90 euros c'est
pas hyper hyper cher c'est un petit
budget je suis d'accord pour une
batterie mais là c'est vingt mille
millions terreur franchement vous avez
de quoi faire
alors voilà donc la boîte ça c'est la
batterie
je réponds ce que ça pourrait être
beaucoup beaucoup plus lourd ça va
franchement le design est pas mal c'est
assez sympa alors c'est du plastique
on va regarder là c'est quoi là ça doit
être tous les accessoires de recharge
on a ici c'est ça alors là c'est
l'adaptateur secteur qui va venir
branché ici micro usb usb donc leur
connectique on est pas mal on recharge
ici je branche je recherche donc ça
c'est l'entraînement suite la sinne
sortie en usb type ah ça c'est une
sortie en usb type c est mon bouton pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre là c'est aussi
une sortie secteur qui je veux recharger
mon smartphone n'importe quoi je prends
je branche là les ports lightning je
peux le mettre pour recharger un iphone
ça marche très très bien là dessus c'est
une petite batterie qui fait 620 grammes
qui est pas hyper hyper lourde là est le
plus bas âge entre 1 % à 20 % de
batterie je vais la recharger
complètement à fond comme ça après on
verra tout ce qu'on peut recharger avec
vous nous direz des batteries externes
comme ça même à 20000 heure par heure il
en existe plusieurs
mais celle là est la vraie intéresser
bon déjà le format est pas non plus trop
rose pailleté re lourde si vous voulez
branché par exemple un iphone ici vous
branchez votre iphone vous voulez
recharger votre smart watch l'a ensuite
directement vous la branchez là vous
pouvez brancher une tablette
ensuite en usb tisser ou pourquoi pas
une surface going rexdale escape par
exemple vous la branchez la vous
l'allumez et ça se rechargent
extrêmement rapidement et autres points
qui vachement intéressant si vous
voyagez comme moi vous êtes souvent avec
le sac à dos et vous allez pas souvent
de batterie ou alors j'ai tout le temps
ça votre smartphone vous consommez
énormément décrit votre batterie lé
pacte et ribéry le vieux smartphone
c'est un peu pour ça que je change ça
vous l'emmenez vous lever c'est avec
vous un peuple âge et un sac à dos voyez
là le volume c'est pas énorme voulu
glisser dedans on voulait emmener
partout avec vous 20 millions perreard
de pouvoir brancher même votre
ordinateur avec et ça franchement c'est
pas mal des fois quand je prends le
train il ya des vieux trams qui ont pas
encore de prise électrique
ça me permet de bosser un petit peu
c'est plutôt cool il existe des
solutions qui sont plus petites mais
celle là avec toutes les connectiques
cas là pour moi elle est vraiment
je voulais partager ce bon plan avec
vous donc je vous dise un produit si
vous intéresse c'est no vous je crois
que ça s'appelle no vous vous pouvez le
trouver vous avez l'irma dans la
description c'est pas le produit le
technologique le plus dingue que ce que
vous présentez par rapport à certains
autres mais par contre je suis là c'est
vraiment un outil pratique et solutionne
pas mal de problèmes dites moi
d'ailleurs ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous voyagez
beaucoup est-ce que vous avez des fois
des problèmes de choc et est ce qu'un
produit comme celui là pourrait vous
aider pourrait vous sauver la vie
voilà vous ne marquez tout ça en bas on
reste connectés parce qu'on va parler de
plein d'autres trucs d'ici quelques
jours on va parler de montres connectés
en est une qui est juste là ça va m
topissime j'ai plein de trucs hyper cool
donc je vous invite à faire une seule
chose c'est à vous abonner et à rester
connectés
[Musique]